[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le 7-8 loisirs toutes vos
idées sorties dans le département et on
commence tout de suite avec le sommaire
de ce numéro du théâtre de la danse de
la musique et du cinéma c'est le
festival des talents clés siens les
clayes-sous-bois du 2 juin au 6 juillet
la ville met ses talents à l'honneur la
coordinatrice de l'événement nous
parlera de la programmation un univers
joyeux entre nature et science fiction
le monde de monsieur broutilles est à
découvrir à guyancourt artiste
pluridisciplinaire décédé en 2016 sa
famille et la ville ont souhaité lui
rendre hommage
et même si les vacances ne sont pas
encore arrivées peut-être pensez-vous
déjà à ou s'inscrire pour la rentrée
mélanie a testé pour nous un pur de
majorettes avec les saint cyrienne de
quoi vous donner quelques idées mais on
commence par une date dimanche c'est la
fête des mères est pourquoi ne pas en
profiter pour assister au concert de
l'orchestré de l'académie de versailles
organisé en partenariat avec
l'association la nouvelle oasis ce
concert sera également l'occasion de
financer la recherche sur le cancer et
de soutenir les enfants touchés par
cette maladie
les membres participent à l'opération un
ghetto pour la recherche menée par
l'association l'étoile de martin on
écoute
aïcha abou bilal présidente de la
nouvelle oasis ça pourrait être un
moment convivial pour la fête des mères
et il y le bénéfice reviendra à la
recherche du cancer par la même occasion
il y aura des ventes de gâteaux pour une
autre association l'étoile de martin ou
ce bénéfice est ré pour la recherche de
cancer en pédiatrie est bien le but de
notre association c'est d'aider les
personnes démunies et les personnes
malade handicapé voilà donc
notre but c'est d'aider le maximum on a
la chance d'avoir la santé je pense que
c'est un capital de voir sa santé et je
pense que faire des événements ou les
pour la recherche des malades c'est ça
peut être que mes bénéfique
les clayes sous bois mais ces
associations et écoles de la ville à
l'honneur la nouvelle édition du
festival des talents que les siens
commence la semaine prochaine spectacles
théâtre musique ou danse le point sur la
programmation avec christelle bidoire de
l'espace philippe noiret qu'est ce que
c'est que le festival des talents que le
site était un festival qui s'étale du 2
juin au 6 juillet qui permet aux
associations et aux établissements
scolaires de valoriser tout le travail
d'une année est de faire des
représentations de d art pratiqué durant
la nuit alors par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'on retrouve comme association qu'est
ce qu'il ya comme spectacle on a la
chance d'avoir des associations avec des
pratiques très variés donc on va avoir
du théâtre classique et moderne
on a du champ du chants de chorales du
chant lyrique et de la musique baroque
on va avoir aussi de la danse vraiment
tous les arts sont représentés et
compris les arts plastiques comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi et donc du
coup c'est un peu un rendez vous
incontournable que le souverain c'est
que des associations des personnes
sondées c'est très locale il ya quand
même un gros effort delà de la ville sur
la communication aussi à l'intérieur
à l'intérieur de la commune donc oui
c'est un rendez vous important
c'est un moment de lien social aussi
entre l'espace noiret les associations
les différents publics
l'idée est vraiment de répondre au fait
que l'espace noir est un centre
socioculturel donc un un lieu de lien
social où on peut se rencontrer et faire
du spectacle tous ensemble donc le 17
juin nous avons une soirée claquettes et
danses irlandaises sept moines bien
toute la diversité qui peut y avoir au
niveau des talents représentés et donc
là alors comment ça va se passer en fait
c'est
les gens peuvent venir danser une chance
de revenir alors ya d'abord un spectacle
avec de la musique live suivi de danse
claquettes et après c'est suivi d'un bal
deux points d'orgue un petit peu cette
édition un peu plus important ce sont
les clefs du cinéma le 3 juin et les
clés si bell le 24 juin lors ça fait
partie de la programmation du festival
mais c'est pas tout à fait lens m'a
profité de la communication aussi des
talents christien pour communiquer sur
ces deux événements sont deux événements
plutôt indépendant
donc on a le festival dès que les clés
du cinéma le sait un petit 3 juin qui
est un festival de courts métrages un
festival régional
et puis les clés les clés si belle qui
est un festival de musiques actuelles
alors ce que pouvait en parler un petit
peu plus notamment la programmation de
l'un et de l'autre alors qu'est-ce qu'on
peut rire alain survaleurs des clés leur
déclin du cinéma vous pourrez retrouver
18 courts métrages de 5 à 16 minutes
pour 3 heures de projection différents
styles on a de la comédie on a du drame
c'est une soit une journée plutôt
familial pour les clés cible alors le 24
juin qu'est ce qu'on pourrait retrouver
ses clés ctic également il s'est essayé
aussi éclectique on propose déjà une
après-midi réservé au vainqueur dé
tremplin rock organisé toute mon année
donc il ya cru quatre groupes qui seront
représentés on est aussi un slameur
cette année name qui est un slameur
locale et puis on à manolo qui vient une
émanation des clips cycling et humanisme
un petit mot sur les tarifs du coût des
différents spectacles et des différentes
notamment les différents festivals
il ya beaucoup d'évènements aussi qu'ils
sont libres oui oui beaucoup de choses
sont entre en entrée libre
certaines associations demandent aussi
une participation au chapeau une très
légère participation de 2 euros l'entrée
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment modique
salaire ça aussi pour pouvoir organiser
leur valeur retrouve à leurs autres
spectacles les clés du cinéma c'est
gratuit
les clés cédait également un univers
fait de métal soudé de matériaux
recyclés c'est le monde de monsieur
broutilles guyancourt lui rend hommage
dans une exposition jusqu'au 24 juin
l'artiste décédé l'an dernier et à
découvrir une dernière fois avant que
ces oeuvres ne soit donnée à ses amis et
à sa famille petit tour de l'exposition
dans ce reportage
[Musique]
des animaux métalliques des créatures
qui semble sorti d'un film de science
fiction des monstres insolite c'est
l'univers de monsieur broutilles dessins
peintures ou sculptures
artiste touche à tout autodidacte ses
oeuvres sont le reflet d'une créativité
sans limite
le premier des outils qui transformait
en d2 et de récupération qui transformé
en animal noise euros
un chien
il était très près de la nature comme il
disait je suis un homme des bois
donc il a vécu dans une caravane
un choix qu'il a tout fait il a profité
de la vie 58 cure initialement pâtissier
monsieur broutilles a suivi une
formation de soudeur qui ont travaillé
dans la métallerie un métier qui lui
servira pour imaginer ses oeuvres décédé
d'une crise cardiaque en 2016 sa famille
a voulu lui rendre un dernier hommage à
guyancourt
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion qu'on
accueille monsieur broutilles parce que
justement c'est à la demande de la
famille que cette exposition de fin de
saison a été programmée c'était vraiment
un hommage
important ici je pense qu'il a vraiment
sa place une exposition qui retrace
quinze années de travail
un monde joyeux et dynamique à l'image
de son créateur
[Musique]
cette semaine mélanie nous propose un
rendez vous sports à saint cyr l'école
elle est allée tester un cours de
majorettes avec les forces syriennes et
ses professeurs ne sont autres que les
élèves de secours
découverte de cette discipline en images
ce que j'ai dans les mains c'est le
bâton l'accessoire principal des
majorettes
je suis au gymnase gérard philipe de
saint cyr l'école avec les 100 syrienne
le club de la ville fondée en 1968 et
mes coaches du jour sont 1re au mal et
alicia bonjour les filles 20 jours alors
elles ont dix ans et 12 ans et surtout
elles sont vice-championnes de france
2007 coach de choix les filles première
question est ce que déjà j'ai la bonne
tenue henri-louis super on commence
retenue alors ça commence comme en un
cours de majorettes magallanes amar le
bateau on doit alors faut toujours avoir
la grosse boule en vain pour commencer
son action bref autant que son bras font
pas c'est toujours la grosse boule au
dessus et la potiche en dessous vit en
dessous alors commencez donc aussi au
dessus
la grosse boule au dessus et la petite
la petite en dessous et puis c'est
difficile d'être majorettes ou pas bon
début en est lui arrivé peu après malgré
ses parents près on est dedans
quentin amours fleurissent appel
vendredi semaine d'octobre
ces souris d'où sa femme sophie seine à
paris
alors eh ben mon combo ayouba trop comme
mes amis alors on fait on va une fille
de 8 ans à l'envers c'est facile en gros
votre blue fang août et pascal ça
[Musique]
annonce enfin c'était dans l'autre
droite ont toujours été comme ça
[Musique]
ou comme ça et à force de faire ça va
vous faire danser beaucoup plus facile à
dire qu'à faire
aujourd'hui on passe la grotte du
biscuit considérant qu elles sont
peuvent eux aussi l'emploi
voilà comme ça en fait j'ai pas tout
compris mais je pense qu on vous garde
en bout d'un moment ça va ronfler ça
passe en dessous ou au dessus de bain
pas facile du tout non en fait pour être
sincère c'est pas que c'est pas facile
c'est qu'ici c'est un peu de
coordination et faut réfléchir
romane et allison est bien expliquée
donc au bout de trois quatre tentatives
ça rentre
la main
oulalala
[Musique]
oh
quelqu'un
roh mané aliciens cinquantaine depuis
six ans il y à 53 majorettes dans le
club et ça s'adresse à tous mine que
vous soyez garçon ou fille alors
pourquoi pas vous camille je vous ramène
un bâton
un rendez vous pour les fans d'harry
potter la possibilité de rencontrer
percy weasley ou plutôt l'acteur qui
l'incarnent chris rankin
il sera samedi 27 mai à l'armoire guide
de versailles pour des séances de
dédicaces
réservation obligatoire et l'association
vivre organise ses 34e min puces à
montigny le bretonneux un événement
incontournable pour venir dégoter de
bonnes affaires avis aux chineurs le
rendez vous est donné dimanche dès 9
heures au parc des sports roger couderc
c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je vous
retrouve vendre des prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]
ouais
oh